the coachella lineup is here and let's
just say it's not what we expect yeah
childish gambino ariana grande and
Taemin Paula are heading to the main
stage as 2019 headliners and here's a
fun fact
last year was Coachella's first time
going without a single rock headliner
yeah it draws controversy but now
they're bringing back the rough man for
me it's still a little underwhelming the
lineup can never top 2018 speech Ella
everyone hyped Beyonce's biggest fan
really hey guys but you know what the
roster isn't quite doing it for fans and
here's why
Kanye West and Justin Timberlake were
rumored to take center stage at the
annual festival
yay reportedly pulled out of
negotiations over stage design though
according to TMZ the traditional stage
was quote artistically limiting I mean
that sounds like Kanye you know he goes
over the top with everything that he
does but I am excited to see childish
gambino this will probably be his last
performance before he retires so I hope
he pulls out all the stops guys totally
and one thing I will say it's pretty
cool that ariana is the youngest artist
ever to headline a festival
she's also only the fourth female ever
to headline which is kind of shocking I
know we do need more artists the big
question across social media and between
me and Katy yeah who is tame impala so
of course we were surprised to find out
they're relatively huge we were in the
minority on that one exactly uh we found
out that they're an Aussie rock band led
by Kevin Parker alongside Dominic semper
and some members of the band pop yeah
and they actually first emerged in the
music scene over 10 years ago in 2007
but they have not put out an album in
like three and a half almost four years
yeah but they are Grammy nominated and I
actually like a lot of their hits so
don't come for us in the comments we
know we listen to them they're good and
someone else on social media who is kind
of not happy is actually burna boy who
is playing on Sunday night he took to
Instagram saying that he's upset that
the festival made his name so darn small
on the flyer okay so he posted this on
his story and that caused some users to
quote fix the lineup creating this
kind of hilarious it really is really
funny it is really funny and of course
people had a whole lot to say about
interest elbow playing at the festival
mostly because he's the sexiest man
alive and also has a DJ career I thought
it was a secret because I didn't yeah
you didn't know I didn't know either
he's pretty good though we looked this
morning guys go check out his Instagram
apparently talks that he talks about
being a DJ yeah all the time it's pretty
impressive though yeah um this user on
social media though actually created
their own dream lineup and it's very
Disney inspired Hilary Duff Hannah
Montana Jonas Brothers I love Disney
stars I would totally go to that I mean
I'd probably pay double than a regular
coach I like a double for anything but
Beach Ella but let's move on
of course as someone I'm excited to see
that is a part of this roster is the
launch kid cudi J Balvin will be there
the 1975 churches bless her for you her
you're excited I'm really excited
who is your dream Coachella lineup I
mean it already happened would be jela
nothing tops that nothing okay mine is
Taylor Swift and I think she deserves
Friday Saturday and Sunday okay she's
gonna get her dream one day but so
brother top-billed artists include
janelle monae bad bunny Kacey Musgraves
a little country twang in there I mean
the list goes on
let us know what you guys think of this
year's headliners who you would like to
see headlined Coachella and make sure to
subscribe to all things et yep and
talked to us across social I met
Courtney underscore Tessa no I'm Katie
underscore crass and bye for now see ya
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]